Darius welcome back to the studio
yesterday after a long game you came and
you said I'm very very tired right now a
pretty short game today how are you
feeling right now well definitely not
tired
no uh to more serious and more serious
now they feel really really nice I feel
really really good
um yeah it was I think nice game
I don't know it doesn't surprise you in
the opening because he was playing very
very quickly and building some sort of a
Time Advantage oh yeah yeah I I just
wasn't sure whether he's still in his
prep or it's some line that he prepared
earlier because you know I I mean I
played this line long time ago so I
wasn't sure whether he would be checking
my old games because I did this line
2015 or 16 I believe
um and this line of the catalog yes yes
and C3 yeah yeah b3a5 here the game
against Nepal like this bishop C3 yeah
but then again was Bishop B7 knifers
other move Knight D2 and he played C5
right away in in that game and I play it
myself in this version thousand I think
he was 16 it was struggle public league
uh yeah against Bindery yeah it's here
down there oh yeah yeah 2016 yeah it was
Czech Republic league and I played 95.
it was after a long game I won uh but
okay well it's probably a bit better but
yeah Queen Seven I didn't know the move
really it's of course very logical I
just
honestly like I wasn't sure what to play
with the Catalan whether to play
um ninja whether to play E4 number when
I was choosing between the various
options as I decided to play Indie and
play D4 and it was one of the options I
looked at but I didn't Envision who
could play Queen C7 I think I had a
bunch of ideas to play and eventually
stick with that was stick with that one
what was the type of position that you
were looking for against Hans did you
have any specifics in mind I just want
to get something playable where he
wouldn't feel so comfortable uh where I
would have a bit more knowledge but I
didn't really work out or maybe it did I
don't know it's tough to say right now
because I won pretty quickly uh but I
don't know where he made honestly his
mistake like this seemed pretty normal
and he was playing yes so I assumed it
was all preparation by him I was on my
own like South Queen C7 pretty much so
yeah I mean I thought what I did was
pretty standard E4 Bishop B7 Bishop B2
yeah it makes it makes a lot of sense
and okay it's a very strange engine is
like zero zero now after if I would have
played it's just advantage to White so I
just don't understand yeah and not only
that but after Knight C4 Queen to A8
seems to have been quite yeah he also
played it very quickly we played very
quickly I was I mean I was thinking
about this move but I was sort of
surprised to see it because I didn't see
particularly in danger on this diagonal
of course it's logical to line up the
queen and Bishop like that with his
battery but on the other hand like
there's I couldn't see any tricks that
would actually work like okay there is
not a four trick but okay I start with
DTX C5 let's say you always have ideas
of Knight to G5 correct so basically
dxc5 and I was thinking he should take
the pawn I really should [ __ ] stick
with the pawn and now I want to play
something like either Knight D6 and for
by 95 or something for that or Knight
d294 also I saw this idea and I thought
why this is better clear here because I
get to D6 square and again whenever he
moves his knight from D5 attack on B7
over Tempo let's say for instance Knight
C3 oh it's a blunder nic3 of course but
um you know Bishop B7 is the point that
Queen is hanging so that's always the
point uh so he doesn't have these jumps
right so uh but still I think what is
just better he's starting with the
Knight on C5 and I was wondering whether
I should play root takes D5 here uh I
was tempted to do this but I felt like
in the end of the day it should equalize
to roughly equal okay okay we're in a
pawn but yeah it Rook C8 91 Bishop G2
King Knight G2 and I thought he would
have some conversations let's have a
four or something at some point
or even now I would think I thought he
would have some conversation here and he
doesn't yeah that's why I didn't do that
uh so that's why I was like okay let's
just go for it 96 takes 95 this looks
very natural uh and yeah actually this
is already lost and by the way he still
haven't actually this was pausing me
even more this was passing me even more
it was his strategy to try to flag me or
something imagine would try to do and
Fabi did so uh but again uh this doesn't
work a bit of a recent strategy yeah
with all of your pieces attacking yeah I
mean everything is just just coming Rook
C4 is very natural I thought H7 as well
yes and it's turning King H7 Rook C4 and
now first F6 or something so now you can
check and then hear an action okay I
didn't see G4 I didn't see root G4 yeah
yeah I I saw that it should be winning
but I didn't just didn't like stop
calculation too early yeah but I thought
so Rook C4 is good enough so I just
decided to play it okay H6 yeah and the
rage for also I mean Mirror May many
moves are winning here of course yeah I
I didn't do it because Queen D6 Rook H6
E5
um
okay I I just how did I wouldn't take on
D5 everything ah okay my God they're
going to defy everything with G6 yeah
everything is winning yeah
[Music]
um
forgot about that yeah but 96 I thought
it's just very clinical because it's
just no chance pretty much right like if
Knight D6 Bishop D5 I just have extra
Pawn which is actually queening upon all
the dark squares and so on
collapsing Darius back-to-back victories
after uh the rest day what did you do
during the rest day to gain so much
confidence and
I just spent some I just spent time with
my family I guess that's the best thing
I could do and have to have some rest
for some family with my wife and the
family in general so so yeah it was it
that was about it guys indeed I just
very very well done tip of the Hat uh
impressive attacking Victory well done
darsh thank you congratulations
absolutely turning our attention to
Fabio